oriented
trial period
um
would you say that this will also bring
out the need for more child care i feel
like i hear from a lot of people who
can't even find child care right now so
how are we going to
make sure they all have a place to go
once they apply for this
question
thank you madam chair thank you senator
this is
a very important bill
uh so a couple questions one one is the
um
do we know child care providers who
have we spoken to them to see their
likelihood of volunteering for this
program
uh in in the follow up
do we do we know uh
uh potential costs what are we looking
and uh one more for me
uh attendance base is that still gonna
happen
are we gonna are we gonna be paying
attendance based
is just for three reimbursement right
okay
great thank you
can you hear me now yep now we're
working
uh
good morning i'm jackie cowell from
early learning new hampshire
i'm here actually representing two
different organizations early learning
new hampshire which we are a statewide
organization
representing
child care providers the families they
serve we're a statewide nonprofit and
i'm also here because the chair of the
new hampshire child care advisory
council couldn't make it she works at
merrimack valley daycare and she was
needed
there at the center and she couldn't
come so
and the new hampshire child care
advisory council is a legislatively
enacted body to advise the health
department of health and human services
as well as consult with the governor and
the department of ed on child care
issues so i'm here today saying that
both of us support this bill
sb 144 again
the main purpose of this again is to
pilot as senator whitley said
the idea of enrollment-based scholarship
it's actually the federal government's
recommendation that this is the best way
to provide what's the child care
scholarship the subsidy system those
families who are income eligible to
receive these services they can't afford
the full cost so therefore the state
pays a portion depending on their income
and then the rest comes from the family
depending on their income as i said and
and so
what this bill does enrollment base
versus attendance base right now we're
in attendance based there's you know um
we're doing better than we had in other
years where you're simply not there you
you don't get the child care scholarship
children are sick the family can't
afford it the child care provider has to
charge in the full cost they don't have
reserves to do it so it's really this
helps level the playing field between a
family who qualifies for their income to
get child care and families who are
private paying
the typical policy in the child care
center is
whether you come or not you pay right
for for a private pay client because
again whether the child is there and not
the teachers there the lights are on the
heat is on et cetera they can't afford
to do it that way so enrollment based
scholarship in the child state child
care scholarship system really again
allows that level of the playing field
that allows programs to open their doors
and say okay
i can i can open my door to a family
who's um
who is uh income eligible i don't have
to worry about not getting paid i don't
have to worry it just that's that's a
worry that gets taken off the provider's
mind and certainly it's terrific for the
family that's the number one reason
you know the family doesn't have to then
their child is sick they lose they lose
time at work they may work at most many
work at hourly um
at hourly rates so they don't get paid
when they don't show up their child is
sick
they have to then pay extra to the child
care center it's a really
uh you know
lose-lose situation so this mitigates
that that's why we support it again the
federal government recommends it as a
policy for states and we're looking
forward to seeing what the um
uh what the cost is the the difference
between our attendance based and this
enrollment based after the pilot is done
uh and to answer your questions yes
so there are some child care programs in
our state uh representative long who
they do um
what they're called enrolled in the
child care scholarship system they're
they open their doors so if a family
comes in who's income eligible require
you know
can get the child care scholarship
they accept those families there are
some who are not enrolled
and our hope for this and that number
we do have the folks in the department
of health and human services behind me
but some years there's a large who taken
child care scholarship and some some
years there's fewer
and we really want everyone in the child
care
programs to open their doors to
any family with any income as long as
again it's a good system and the
enrollment base makes it a better system
more likely they will take children who
whose families are income eligible
[Music]
um yeah yeah on online seven it says
regardless of income
so it says the child care scholarship or
subsidy plays a significant role in
ensuring all new hampshire families can
access quality safe and reliable child
care regardless of income
uh interestingly that doesn't
that was maybe an error yeah
so what it is is um the child care
scholarship in new hampshire system goes
up to what's um about i think it's like
of the state median income so in other
words um it's uh it's a family of three
you but you guys know this better than i
do probably forty five thousand dollars
a year earning um so anyone under that
but again if if you um are receiving uh
tanf if you're at the lower end of the
of the income spectrum you receive more
scholarship and as you raise your income
you get less scholarship but it's capped
at either 250 percent of federal poverty
level which is still
like i said about family of three forty
five thousand dollars a year
thank you and i have one more question
um
on page two on line four
it says the department shall include
as part of the biennial budgetary
process the full cost to provide
enrollment-based reimbursement
rather than
attendance-based payment to child care
providers who accept
so can you explain to me because it
looks like to me that regardless of how
this
three-month trial comes out we're doing
this no matter what
is that is that my correct understanding
that is the intent of course would be
through the budgetary process anyway but
yes i understand what you're saying did
you want to
that language thank you for for that
question that language was added as a
result of some significant negotiation
with the department i think there was a
lot of support for actually just making
the change
but um
this was
uh
you know agreeing to a three-month pilot
rather than a longer pilot or just
making the change was the result of
negotiations
um but here's the thing you know
depending on the cost you know
the you know the legislature can do what
it will do so really it just allows the
agency it requires the agency to put it
in their budget request but then of
course the legislature has a very
important role in determining whether it
actually makes it into the budget
okay and can you just explain real quick
that where it says regardless of income
miss can can be misconstrued because i
think you mean that
regardless of income people will be able
to get child care so that the people
that can afford it can but i think as
you read the bill it sounds like it's
saying that regardless of your income
you can qualify for this program thank
you for the question so that the so
you're referring to line
seven correct yep so in the statement of
findings it's really that sort of
regardless of income is more a general
statement where we say the child care
scholarship plays a significant role in
ensuring that equality so it's not
saying it's not specifically saying that
someone has access to the scholarship
program regardless of income
but that the that the the program in
general plays a role in that balance of
who can access it or not happy to look
at an amendment though if that works i
just feel like it might be a little sure
um
misleading
yes to people
and we don't want to
run into
problems further down the road
thank you madam chair and maybe we could
add something you know just referring
directly to the
income guidelines and statute or
regulations or something like that
great thank you
are there any questions for miss cowell
representative
just uh long clarity on uh line six
but the way i read this is that if i
could afford child care i'm all set
this program helps for those that can't
so am i correct uh with assuming that
attendance base
currently is on a sliding steel
scale and that enrollment base would be
a
pre-determined amount agreed to by the
provider gotcha um actually
attendance-based and enrollment-based um
is different only in how it's paid by
the state so
attend it so there's no pre-agreed
amount what it means is for whatever
they're scheduled for
like private play clients they the state
pays their portion
and the families still pay their portion
whether they show up or not but um
attendance-based is
whether they come they they may not come
and the state doesn't pay depending on
how how many they've been if they've
been out all week etc etc so it puts the
family at risk of having to pay the
difference that the state doesn't pay
with attendance based okay uh follow-up
thank you um
i'm looking for
where this
is an incentive for the provider ah
so yeah it may not be is there better is
there a better guarantee for the
provider
there is this scenario there is because
of how it's paid out by the state so if
they're enrolled if the family is a
child care scholarship eligible family
right this is the only this only affects
these families who are income eligible
of course
so the difference is it's more
guaranteed because the state will pay
what they're scheduled to attend even if
they are absent so it's again what
senator whitley said like a business you
can count on certain income all the
private pay clients pay that way it's
just leveling that playing field the
same method of of counting on income
coming in
okay and uh one more for me
just the um
uh just to clarify on the uh
hhs budget request so if this um
you know if this report comes out that
it's not working
then i would assume they
wouldn't put it in their budget request
yeah correct
uh
that's a good it's a good question but i
think you know what this does is trying
to figure i
the department can can speak to that but
the department is if it's affordable my
understanding is department thinks
enrollment based is a good way to go
right so it's not and and other states
that do it again it's leveling the
playing field but if so i don't think
it's that it wouldn't work it's just
what it would cost
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question
um
this entire bill as amended uh
was created to
allow parents to remain in the workforce
right that's right
considering the fact that the workforce
consists mainly of
three
work shifts
and most day cares are open during the
nine to five or six or six to six
how many
uh child care facilities do we have that
facilitate the three to eleven and
eleven to 7 group of
parents that may be eligible
for the scholarship
uh there aren't that many representative
um
again hhs may have a better and accurate
number
what's interesting is that
i believe as part of the arpa
discretionary funds for dhhs there's a
look into
how to expand and have more of those
other shipped hours at the same time
i've been in the field for 30 plus years
in new hampshire many centers have
sometimes tried to open up those
offerings and what ends up happening is
the children the moms and dads
understandably want their children in
their own bed or they want them in they
don't want them in a center you know
overnight
it's it's been um when when a lot of
programs that i've been aware of
anecdotally that offer it and decide to
try it parents just don't want
that option they want to figure out a
way to get reimbursed or help for
someone else to be in the family or
um or in a home but not in the center
but they they might be able to answer
you in terms of what if there's any
plans underway
i think you may know that even with it
even with the center-based i think
representative rice sort of mentioned it
too that that you know
many many families can't access it now
even in the day
that whatever we can do yeah
thank you you're
welcome are there any further questions
all right saying none thank you very
much thank you
um up next will be karen hebert
morning
thank you my name is karen hebert and i
am the division director for the
division of economic and housing
stability
and i would like to introduce deborah
nelson who is a bureau chief in the
department directly behind me for the
bureau of child development and head
start collaboration and i would like to
join have her join me to answer some of
the more particular questions that i've
been hearing so far that she could
provide information for
but
so this
first of all i do want to thank senator
whitley for the work that she has done
a tremendous work that she has done in
supporting child care in the state
this bill is really all about
supporting families
better as well as our workforce in the
state
um
so in order to
this as senator whitley mentioned this
is one
step one particular
thing that we can do to support child
care in the state and strengthen it
and one of the
things that this does certainly is
looking at
the
cost
for an enrollment-based program compared
to
the current
absentee billing program that we have
essentially if
we are able to show that this
really has been effective for families
it may increase the utilization of the
child care scholarship program this is a
federally funded program that at the
moment is arguably underutilized and we
would like to see an increase in that
so
any questions i'm happy to answer or
representative long big amount of chairs
uh
so the ccdf is underfunded i mean not
underfunded it's underutilized
and uh
you're hoping that the enrollment base
will
increase utilization of this funding
yes so there at the end of
uh calendar year 2021
there were 799 providers across the
state
608 of them at the end of that year were
currently enrolled in the scholarship
program accepting
families who were eligible for the
scholarship
so we anticipate that we could do better
and increase the number of providers who
are able to
use the scholarship program for families
that would increase the number of
families able to
have
child care so that they can get back to
the workforce
seeing them thank you very much
thank you up next is rebecca watkowski
who is asked for two minutes and does
good morning my name is rebecca
voikovsky i'm the kids count policy
director at new futures new futures is a
non-profit nonpartisan advocacy
organization that educates advocates and
collaborates to improve the health and
wellness of new hampshire's kids and
families
so i'm here today to talk about our
strong support and partnership with
senator whitley early learning new
hampshire and our state partners and
looking at how enrollment-based billing
can be used to help families access
child care scholarship i'm just going to
speak to a couple of questions although
i've handed in some robust written
testimony about how access to child care
is primary prevention it's also good for
the workforce but we know that it helps
mitigate
aces and trauma that children may face
and we know that is an issue for our
state in speaking with senator whitley
just now i think that a suggestion if
the committee would take it would be to
just strike lines six and seven instead
of trying to come up with
additional language i think that's a
finding i don't think that it's
important to the context of the bill and
i believe senator whitley agrees with me
there
i just want to emphasize a couple of
things number one as
jackie cowell spoke from early learning
new hampshire enrollment-based billing
is promoted by the federal government as
a policy around child care development
block grant dollars it's also a explicit
authorized use for federal discretionary
child care development block grant
dollars so
when covid hit there were
different relief dollars there were
specific dollars for child care in this
program this is an authorized way to use
those discretionary dollars just so the
committee knows that the other thing
that i want to talk about is that
the state did use enrollment-based
billing during the pandemic
is a way to stabilize the child care
market it wasn't a
it wasn't
a specific program change they used
disaster billing they could fill you in
on exactly how that works but to kind of
answer representative long's questions
about whether or not this would be
a program that worked we know that it
did work
i don't have the data of how many more
families but we know that it stabilized
the market we know that it's important
from our family's perspective that we
hear that it allows them to really
consider child care if they know that
they're not going to be penalized if
their kid is out we still have
restrictions around covet if you're out
for five days um
so i'll just represent that we're in
strong support of this bill we have
worked with senator whitley and state
partners i'm happy to answer any
questions but
seeing none thank you very much
okay so i'm going to close the public
hearing on
am i
yes i'm going to close the public
and then
oh we're doing good okay
i'm gonna open the public hearing on
senate bill 326
as soon as the clerk is ready
are you ready okay
yes senator becky whitley
thanks
thank you madam chair and good morning
again to the members of the committee uh
for the record my name is becky whitley
and i'm honored to serve new hampshire
senate district 15 including the
communities of concord henniker
hopkinton and warner
so this bill senate bill 326 has
introduced established an office of
early childhood to coordinate
consolidate and integrate early
childhood programs
as our current system as our system is
currently designed
there remains an alphabet soup of state
agencies
that you know provide a variety of
services to our young children and
families and as fem and many families
and even as a legislator i can attest to
that this system is confusing
complicated and hard to access
so the idea of creating a single office
of early childhood will actually empower
our families with a one-stop shop for
the care and support that they need
the amended version that you have in
front of you looks a little different
than how the bill was introduced it
retains the important findings that led
to the bill but instead of actually
creating the office it directs the
commissioner of dhhs in consultation
with the commissioner of department of
administrative services and the
commissioner of the department of
education the child advocate counsel for
thriving children all the people we know
who are experts and children
to develop a plan to actually create the
office by november 1st 2022.
so this the pursuant to the bill this
process and timeline will track
with the steps that are actually already
in motion through the council for
thriving children and work at the dhhs
and ensure that there is a plan in place
um answering some of the questions that
were raised in the senate in again in
time for the next budget cycle right
so i just wanted to sort of back up
towards about why this is really
important i think folks on this
committee know well that research across
a lot of disciplines has shown that the
early years of children's life are
incredibly critical to healthy brain
development
i think it uh you know what shows us is
that you know what happens in a child's
early years will be so important to
their readiness for school and of course
their readiness to participate in daily
life
so i think in addition to what we know
the research says about the benefits to
children i think it's important to also
look you know we are legislators it's
important to look
at the financial side of things and
research has shown us that there is a
significant return on investment
in early childhood if we're investing in
early childhood we see
you know a lifetime of higher earnings
improved education outcomes reduced
criminal justice cost
that research is old and it's well
established that we will see those cost
savings if we invest in early childhood
so as i mentioned before the state of
new hampshire currently does have
investments in early childhood
but it's a very fragmented system it's
just you know as with a lot of things
you know things are fragmented through
various funding streams that is no fault
of state agencies it's just the way that
we do things in new hampshire
so because of the state government has
already identified that this is a
problem
the department of ed and the department
of health and human services already
have a team that is looking at more
integration of early childhood they are
already on the way to doing this work
and moving towards a more integrated
early childhood system and i think the
department can speak to that work but
they do have a team looking at this
across
the two different departments and i
think from their perspective you know
eventually creating an office of early
childhood
can
hopefully result in more efficiencies um
and then of course from my perspective
thinking about families you know greater
access to the services that our families
need so desperately
so as you can see from the sponsors and
just from your own work early childhood
really is a bipartisan issue
on
january 23 2020 governor sununu issued
an executive order creating the council
for thriving children and in that same
executive order the governor also
directed dhhs and doe
to us to work towards establishing a
joint office of early childhood and
education
so it's right there in the executive
order this is just the legislation that
is necessary to effectuate that
executive order
so the purpose of this bill is to build
on that vision to keep us moving forward
of course you know within state
government we always need those
measures of accountability that keep the
work moving forward
the original version of the bill
certainly had a phased-in approach i
think this this plan also looks at that
phased-in approach
um and i will note too that there are a
lot of other states that are looking at
this um colorado california connecticut
georgia hawaii massachusetts montana new
mexico
utah virginia washington
uh they are already moving in this
direction many other states uh this
session and last session
also have bills to move into some more
uh in this direction
so i think we can all agree that the uh
you know the first years of a child's
life are so critically important and
that you know
this
you know those years should not be sort
of caught in bureaucratic
mess and morass so i think um you'll
hear from other folks why it's so
important to have the full attention and
focus that's equal to the importance of
this time of life and how this will
really work to integrate services for
maximum impact of these investments so
thank you for your consideration i'm
happy to take any questions
are there any questions representative
yokela
thank you and thank you for taking the
question
you
um
stated that
early childhood
is um you know an important time in a
child's uh in a person's life
but you didn't explain really what
this
what the role of government is in the
early childhood and what
what it is
um trying to do
as far as
are we
we're not actually parenting the this
child um and so what is what is it doing
as far as like the goal of this office i
guess is is it just educating parents
about the opportunities for
services and of the needs that are
offered by the state
currently so it's more of a um
uh
way to sh to you know advertise for that
or is it um
something else that i'm i'm
not clear about thank you yeah thank you
for the question
so already in new hampshire there are a
lot of state dollars going to early
childhood child care right there's both
state and federal dollars in the child
care scholarship program
there's state and federal dollars on
other programs
that impact
early childhood but they're sort of
dispersed around state government and i
think the whole idea is that
um to maximize those investments that
are already there right and then to
leverage those investments we have a ton
of federal money coming in to maximize
and then leverage those investments we
need a more integrated system it's too
spread out and there's not full
attention about how to maximize those
investments
so i think the education piece that you
described is incredibly important how
how do families access you know the
support that's so desperately needed i
think that will
absolutely be a piece to it so it's
multi-pronged does that answer your
question
yes thank you
is there any other ques oh
representative altschiller
thank you madam chair and thank you
senator whitley for bringing this
forward
on the first page of the bill line part
four um four lines 16 through 20.
um do we have any
are there any reports that i know
everybody
because of the nature of the the
response to the pandemic and
making sure that families got those
supports when
the public health
issues around the public health
challenges
created around the pandemic meant that a
lot of
nonprofits that support our agencies
were scrambling we were we were
scrambling um
but now now that we are looking at how
do we do this better
because
that scramble uncovered a lot of gaps
which is
why this is here um do we have any
documentation from
the department of health and human
services and
um
the doe about like
what they did
thank you for that question um so
they're
yes they're i think um so after the
executive order created the council
uh
maybe a year later
the council for thriving children which
is a you know it's a public-private
partnership so the chairs of that
council are doe and dhhs representation
there is an executive director so it is
a public private partnership
there was they issued a strategic plan
on early childhood in the summer of
2020.
so that you know sort of provides the
benchmarks probably that you're
identifying and then right now they are
in the process of updating that
strategic report
through a very robust process that
others behind me can discuss and that
should be ready
before the next budget cycle so
the fall or just
december and so i think in that you
probably will see more about what was
exposed throughout the pandemic
follow-up
thank you thank you very much so if i
understand you correctly what you're
saying is that that strategic plan will
actually
more or less provide the framework for
um for this
for this
child care
initiative that's my understanding and
that's why we really tracked the
timeline their timeline and track that
uh in the bill
thank you
representative alessia
thank you madam share
thank you senator for taking my question
i'm not sure if this will or will not
have anything to do with the actual
scholarship program
but if a family is receiving services
through dhhs
and they apply for the scholarship
and they get it they're approved
wouldn't it in any way lessen what they
get
as a
family
food stamps or
other
funds that they may receive from dhhs
i think that's a question for dhhs i
don't want to provide misinformation
about that but thank you for that
important question thank you
are there any other questions
representative long
thank you madam chair uh so just
to clarify in my mind
this is a collaborative this is an
attempt at a collaborative effort so if
i'm taking the opportunity of a service
that new hampshire offers
i may not be aware of all the other
services because there isn't a
collaborative effort so would i be more
aware
setting up this joint office
on other opportunities i may need with
my children's early education thank you
for the question i think that's exactly
right um it as i discussed with
representative it's about it's a both uh
you know leveraging our current
investments and also you know more
helpful for families the other thing i
wanted to mention and you made me think
about that is that you know in new
hampshire
you know we have to move to a place
where we're less crisis focused and that
we're more future focused and that we
are you know not just throwing a lot of
money at problems once they happen but
we're preventing problems and that we're
planning for the future down the road
and we know that whatever is coming down
from washington there continues to be
significant bipartisan support for
investment in early childhood what that
looks like and how much is very unclear
but there will be significant federal
investment fairly soon in early
childhood both on the child care side
and potentially pre-k
and if that happened tomorrow we would
not be ready in new hampshire for that
so this office provides the necessary
structure
for incoming federal dollars that we
know are coming great thank you
are there any further questions
up next is rebecca
watkowski i know i'm killing that name
my name was stephen so i should have
stayed with that
and she has um yes she does have written
testimony and she's asked for two
minutes
can i pass this
hi again rebecca boykovsky kids count
policy director at new futures
i'm here in strong support of senate
bill 326 as amended again i'm here to
talk and represent the strong
collaboration between senator whitley
and our partners at dhhs and doe around
this bill i also want to share that i am
a parent representative on the council
for thriving children and i am also the
co-chair of the strategic planning
subcommittee i can't speak on behalf of
the council for thriving children but if
there are any questions around the work
of that committee i can speak for my
experience i just want to confirm
a couple of things that senator whitley
spoke about the idea of how to better
integrate our early childhood system
from birth through eight has been an
ongoing theme for a long time it's not a
new idea
new hampshire actually received in 2019
before the pandemic 26.8 million dollars
in the preschool development grant
excuse me the preschool development
grant is a misnomer for most people it
has nothing really to do with the
development of preschool in new
hampshire it has to do with the
development of a better coordinated
system for kids and families and if you
happen to see
as part of that governor sununu's office
created this great visual i'm sure our
friends at the department could show you
about what that structure is it created
early
early childhood integration teams in
dhhs and doe and also created connection
to this larger council for thriving
children and the council for thriving
children has diverse membership parent
representation advocates representation
from all different fields understanding
that children exist within families and
those families may have different
touches in parts of the system but we
have to acknowledge that it's not easy
for families to navigate
so i say that all to emphasize that this
bill is really timed with the work
that's going on right now it allows a
touch with the legislature to understand
what the ongoing process is and to make
an evaluation on how we best leverage
existing funding streams how we improve
on so the internal side and also on the
external side for kids and families
and the last thing i'll say is that
preschool development grant it ends in
december
so this bill is also tied with the end
of that so that we can look at what
parts of that investment
can we sustain or should we sustain and
how we can we best do it in a way that
is fiscally responsible for our state
i'm happy to answer any questions but
other than that i'll refer to my
testimony that i submit submitted are
there any questions
thank you so much madam chair
for um and thank you for coming and
presenting this important work
um as a mother of a child with autism
and twins
i know the importance of those early
childhood years and the payoff that
comes later on
and we have used those services so thank
you
what i wanted to clarify was
what specific years are we talking about
when we reference early childhood
so is it birth
thank you for that question that's
really great so um
i'll explain a little bit the preschool
development grant looked at
birth through five but our state's
council for thriving children looks
birth through eight so there's a warm
handoff to doe
are there any further questions
seeing that oh no i see one sorry thank
you representative ocala thank you thank
you for taking the question
do you see this as um
just a reorganization of our current um
system or do you think that this is
um
leaving those systems in place and kind
of
creating an overarching um structure on
top of them to you know
facilitate the
uh ex the the information sharing about
those programs and coordination between
them
i'll speak for my
role on the council thriving children in
view of this i don't see it as building
out another government structure i see
it as through the process of strategic
planning looking at how we are serving
families and creating a more streamlined
approach to providing that and ensuring
that it gets out to more families so i
would say it's an assessment of what
we're doing well maybe what we're not
doing so well and how to improve it with
existing dollars
there's always the opportunity that we
may be leaving some dollars on the table
for kids and families
so you know i think that
adding in my role as an advocate for
early childhood programming
it really is starting to look at how the
systems are coordinated how are you
catching families
and really giving them the skills to be
thriving and well
you know one example is looking at
you know home visiting programs how are
we getting new moms into home visiting
programs and how's that tied to family
resource centers that also provide
services for
you know
other family members within that
community so it's really i think we've
had a history of providing one service
and looking at a child in a silo
this is really building up a system that
looks like look at a child existing
within a family and ensuring we're
giving them access to services that
allows to get them to keep the family
intact and to be thriving and well
because that's ultimately what we all we
representative smith
thank you for taking my call my question
um
do you work with pediatricians as well
to get them
um you know if a kid is slow to talk
like my daughter was
um
you know cognitive not where they're
supposed to be so do you work and
educate
educate the doctors of what
you know they need to look for to give
children services yeah thank you for the
question just to clarify i'm not a
service provider so we do advocacy and
pediatricians are a population that we
aim to include in all the programming
that you said okay thank you thanks
there any further questions
seeing none thank you thank you
up next is karen hebert from dhhs she's
good morning again my name is karen
hebert director for the division of
economic and housing stability for the
department of health and human services
so i just wanted to comment that you
know certainly this bill and again
thanking senator whitley for her work
this bill really brings
us enables us to take
some pretty significant steps
towards really creating a solid
foundation
moving forward which is that plan and
identifying what is it
that
would answer the question can the
various services and programs across
multiple agencies
that relate to early childhood
can they be more cooperative together
and more effective
and efficient in a single office
there is certainly fragmentation across
the
services multiple services for early
childhood and as the representative from
new futures has pointed out
there are
many reaching branches to each of those
where she may have access to groups like
pediatricians where the department in
our particular role is not a that is not
a typical
uh
connection that the department would
make so there are multiple different
services and we're really this basically
provides the opportunity to have that
long overdue conversation so that we can
really look at the number of services of
early childhood and make some
determinations of how can we build a
plan
that would create
a better
so we're hoping that the work that has
been done over the last few years by the
council for thriving children as well as
the preschool development grant
could really inform this particular plan
and that we could use that work that
we've already done to start building off
of that
and uh really take a a
look under a microscope at how to how to
create a build a better
system thank you
okay so i have a quick question um
so
for this i see that um
when
all the bodies get together and decide
what's going on is this going to create
new positions or are these going to be
positions that we're going to pull from
each department for people that already
are doing these jobs
thank you for the question so that is
the necessary part of the conversation
for all of these entities to gather
together and look at every aspect of how
we're delivering those services what
resources are needed what resources
could be streamlined where we can work
more collaboratively together and not
duplicate services as well so every
every component of this commissioners
from dhhs doe the office of early
childhood
excuse me child advocate
and the department of admin services and
the council for thriving children need
to have those conversations to make
that
recommendation in this particular plan
and although november is not that far
away i think we're optimistic that this
is something that we could do to
formulate that kind of a plan
representative ocala
thank you thank you for taking the
question
um
what's
so
what is holding you back from
from
doing
the
like the um a large portion of this work
now especially um you know what services
hhs offers
you know
and
there's a bunch of
services that you may be aware of that
you can point other people to if they
were seeking help
um as far as the
advocacy
as far as the awareness for you know
doctors or families that are in need of
services
how what is the struggle for being able
to um
to
advertise essentially those services out
to the people that need them
uh i forgot my other question so i'll
let you answer that one first
sure thank you for the question
so
the bill basically ignites some energy
into
creating
the steps that we need to to be able to
look at this across multiple services
um
and i think that we are all so
um focused on our competing priorities
in each division each
department each program that it's hard
to stop and start focusing on it but i
think that the work that we've already
done through the council for thriving
children and the preschool development
grant is pretty significant that has
been moving forward so i think that this
basically enables us to build upon
the work that's been done
and continue
moving in that direction
um
not sure if that answers your question
follow-up
thank you um
and thank you for taking this follow-up
um
so
there's already this commission that was
um
formed by the governor
and so there's already some
enthusiasm
i would say uh towards addressing this
issue
and i don't believe
that
um representatives from the agency
whether it be children and family or all
these people that are listed would
um decline an invitation to go to that
um to
to
the currently created
um
uh what is it called uh
board
uh
the currently created council yeah to to
try and form this
this uh
plan i guess so
i guess what what is this adding that
that they couldn't
do by just going to that council now and
creating the plan
so
thank you i think that um
you know the intent to be able to
develop a plan that may inform the
department's budget and what we may end
up
moving forward and if we were to create
an office of early childhood we
do that very methodically very
thoroughly but also to inform policy to
inform
the budget going forward and i think
that this is certainly motivating a
number of the agencies all of us to get
together and make that happen
is there a barrier that's in the way at
the moment i think the barriers are
certainly
um
you know we could speak to our own
barriers and with the complexities that
this involves incredible complexities
across
multiple agencies and to have
a
a means for
um
you know creating that pathway and
having us come together i think is has
been an important part of this
particular bill
it's not to say that we couldn't do it
otherwise however
i think that to enable us to really
bring all of these groups together
that
that's what the bill essentially does
and
looking at
some of those barriers may include also
the fact that as i mentioned earlier we
all have
highly competing priorities
that we're contending with
and so trying to identify really across
multiple programs that we're basically
saying this is a significant priority
to all of these agencies and being able
to come together including the ones that
are named in here
department of administrative services
the office of child advocate the
multiple components that make up the
the bill basically enables those
one more follow up
it seems like that
from the testimony that i've heard so
far that um
it that
creation of this or the integration of
this was kind of within the scope of
the um the executive orders
um creating this council for the
thriving children and so the creation
or or um
that that executive order was
essentially this bill that says we want
you to come up with something to create
this uh
create this childhood
um
streamlined process
of services
and
um so i'm just i'm still just struggling
with uh the
wh how
how this differs essentially from the
scope of work that the um that the
thriving children uh council worked on
are you aware of so the council for
thriving children so the early childhood
integration teams that were pulled
together for that really
includes the department of education the
department of health and human services
and community programs so there's a lot
that makes
that up however this expands upon that
tremendously
including the office of child advocate
including the department of admin
services along with dhhs
and the department of ed um of education
to look at formalizing
the creation of an office what can we
formalize
across those departments that they can
each inform it
we want to do this the right way and
looking at this as an opportunity to
take perhaps
perhaps
the only opportunity that we have to be
able to do that do it once we want to do
one more thank you so since thank you
for for taking the follow-up since you
you seem to have stressed multiple times
about wanting to be thoughtful and take
our time to get it right
and
yet the um
the deadline is november 1st right and
so can you comment about how you think
that
the deadline of november 1st allows you
to be
take that thoughtful methodical get it
right approach absolutely so the
november first deadline is to create a
plan
just the plan
the implementation of that plan
is another phase
and what that looks like how it may
be altered or changed beyond the plan
representative long
thank you madam chair thank you
uh so
oftentimes in government local i i
do this in manchester a lot is
collaborations
so
a lot of entities they want to keep
their gig right i don't blame them
they're a non-profit they're doing well
in their sector however so collaborating
with other um
you know what other entities of the same
fashion
is this to help
that collaboration so even though
we may not
you know we have all these entities out
there we need somebody to get them
together
to make sure we're getting the our best
practice efforts in place is that
part of this office doing like for
example the oca
right what do we need in oca we have
dcyf we have hhs we have but the oca
sort of puts a couple of
um a couple of issues into one basket
which helps us instead of looking at
three different entities we look at the
oca and those entities are included in
one basket sure is that the same effect
so i would state that i believe the
office of child advocate had a bit of a
different purpose behind it
um so
the office of early childhood
i mean this this intent yes to answer
your question is to be able to create a
plan of what so again the representative
from new futures mentioned of ju trying
to identify what is work working really
well
and what isn't where can we make
improvements to improve the system of
services for families
for children so that's what a lot of
this is what we're hoping to accomplish
in
as we start convening to talk about the
development of a plan
okay and uh just to follow up
i
i've heard reference of oca the office
child advocate i don't see it in here i
don't see the oca in here
it's in here
line 27
boy people love correcting me
oh i do see it i didn't highlight it
okay very good thank you you're welcome
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question
i'm still struggling a little bit here
um
two years ago
on january 23rd the governor issued the
executive order
i'm not understanding in
where what has
taken place
how far you've come in the last two
years
that
your
belief is that you can accomplish
the task
by november 1st
it's really a struggle for me
can you answer that
i think it would be helpful if uh the
chief debra nelson were to answer
questions about the progress of the
council for thriving children she's a
bit closer to that than i am i still
need a pink card from her for the last
bill also and i think if she's oh
and if you're going to speak on this one
i need you to fill out a pink card for
hi members of the committee debra nelson
i'm the bureau chief for child
development head start collaboration at
dhhs and i'm also a member of the
council for thriving children and i'm
also on the planning committee for the
office of early childhood and the
strategic plan going forward so lots of
irons in the fire like all of my
colleagues here
and um when you ask about the progress
and you know that's such a good question
because
we
we had a a huge pandemic that really
derailed our forward momentum on you
know this work of integrating all of the
services and the opportunities across
the state you know within and across
dhhs to doe and with our partners in the
community however despite the pandemic
through the efforts of the council and
in particular the
early childhood integration team at dhhs
and then our our counterpart at doe and
then the integration of the integration
teams we we also meet joining the
integration teams with integration
everywhere i am just astounded at the
progress that's been made you know where
the rubber hits the road of services
like in in this past year especially
being able to leverage dollars i take
our bureau of child development head
start collaboration dollars put them on
the table with maternal and child health
and public health and we co-fund things
and we work together when i develop
policy we bring in our child care
licensing partners and our dcyf partners
and you know advocates and others to
look at the policy that we are you know
looking at changing our rules and so you
know just the fact of having worked you
know monthly meetings couple of hours
every month over a year with a set
agenda and addressing specific topics of
different areas relative to an
integrated effort in early childhood has
really brought us a long way and i think
um if the if the committee is interested
we could look we could look at an up you
know an update report from the
integration team so you can just see
some of the work but i think some of the
same things that are most exciting to me
is when i get a call from public health
and say i understand that you fund pro
solutions you know care solutions which
is a online platform for providers to be
able to take courses online in their
jammies or whatever and many of them
free is there any way you can put up a
course for us on environmental health
because we want to make sure that child
care and early childhood programs
understand the impact of their the
environments in which children are
learning playing thriving and the staff
are working so we said sure so we pulled
our money we're going to get those
courses up online they'll be free and
available so that's just one tiny sliver
of an example of true integration their
money our platform and getting it out
free of charge another example and this
one has been underway for a number of
years as our watchmego development
screening system that was truly taking
slices of money from across like four or
five different parts of the system
pulling it together with no general
funds just you know whatever federal
funds we could cobble together in
creating a developmental screening
system for new hampshire new hampshire
didn't have one so i hear you know you
talk about your children and how do we
make sure they get services early well
there's one answer so you know one of
the things that we'll be doing through
an integrated effort is is really
strengthening and expanding that
developmental screening system so that
all children who need support and
services are identified early and the
families get the support they need to
make sure those children are on track so
those are specific examples i could go
on and on you know there there are many
but i think as
ms hebert described we still have a ways
to go we still have you know some of our
barriers in terms of how our funding is
defined for what it can be used and what
it cannot be used for and who the
population that is defined federally for
us of who gets served by those funds but
i think you know i've i've been in the
state for 15 years now with the state of
new hampshire before that i was at
university of new hampshire doing early
childhood grants
and i've seen over my 15 years such huge
progress in working hand in hand you
know within and across the department so
i think this is an exciting time sort of
a perfect storm for new hampshire to
really move forward on on a plan that
will formalize some of the integrations
that we have we have begun so we've
begun we have a long way to go
thank you
representative g simone
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question
um i keep hearing about
barriers with funding
once
the collaboration is done and the work
is done do those barriers go away or do
they continue
the barriers will continue our
approaches will
will try to work together so so there's
options to braid or blend funds some
some funds you can pray together like
i'll put my dollars on the table with
yours and we'll have a bigger pool to
support families and children but i
can't
you know maybe give your department my
dollars you know it's just we have to
pool it whereas blending means we
actually put the funds together and have
a bigger pot of money so you know those
are the kind of federal barriers that we
face but states i won't say get around
the states work with what they can work
are there any further questions
seeing none thank you
thank you what
oh i'm sorry representative alessia
thank you for recognizing me man i
didn't even see your hand i actually had
the question for uh karen hebert from
dhhs who was originally okay at the
thank you so much for coming today and
sharing your testimony with us we we
very much appreciate it i'm sorry to
repeat the same question that i asked
the senator
i'm just curious it's referencing
if persons are currently receiving
search services from dhhs
and they apply for a scholarship
does it lessen the funds that they they
do receive from other programs or
does it
just even out i'm so glad you asked that
question because it's a really great
question um
so the the answer is yes it could um so
what we're currently doing there's a
quite a large project across the
department that we're looking at what's
known as the cliff effect
where uh individuals who if they have an
increase in their income
may find that they become ineligible for
certain programs yet the increase in the
income does not
outweigh what they were
finding helpful in benefits so
one of the things is looking at across
the eligibility programs child care snap
tanf for example medicaid
what are the eligibility requirements
and what happens when somebody
now
applies for tanf for example how is that
impacting their eligibility for child
care
is there disregard of certain public
assistance programs
to be considered in eligibility for
other programs so there's a lot of
alignment that we really should be
looking at so we've started that process
very recently
follow up
i want to thank you for that i live in
boston
and we're a poor town
and when programs come come up like that
the first thing they say when i
approach them is
i don't want to apply for that because
it's going to lessen my food stamps or
i'm not going to get this so it's really
important to know that so i want to
thank you
it's not a question
i want to thank you for considering
sharing that information going forward
and there are some of those rules or
some are are embedded into federal
regulations that we can't change so what
is it that we can so there are some
eligibility criteria that we can look at
changing but we want to make sure if we
make a change what kind of impact is it
going to have
in many other aspects so we don't want
to do more harm than good thank you
thank you are there any further
questions
see none thank you very much thank you
okay so we're running past our time so
i'm going to hold you to the time you
put on your pink card jackie cowell has
good morning i'm jackie cowell from
early learning new hampshire
and the only thing i would add um or
emphasize is that this particular bill
really gives a legislative impromature
on this there's an endorsement you're
just saying the legislature is saying
yeah let's have that plan right and and
it likes the excitement i do think it's
possible we would keep going year after
year without doing it even if it's even
though it's in an executive order
without the without the legislature
saying like this you know this is
important to do to have this plan
you know i would love i
asked the house to do the same that the
senate just said yes let's have this
plan have that have this branch of
government be part of saying it's
important to do and i do think it's
possible by november 2022 because
there's been a lot of work that people
will be building on over the years
are there any questions
representative levesque
hi thank you for recognizing thank you
for taking my question has any of
because um invariant we have early
childhood learning center and many
other towns and cities to do also has
any teachers reached out to you willing
to help out with this office or any of
the department heads from them reached
out to you about this
and i didn't catch all of that and i
apologize would you didn't catch all of
it my ears are great sorry
has any of the uh early childhood
learning centers department heads or
teachers reached out to you willing to
work with you or
that question sorry
yeah this is very the council for
thriving children is very much a
public-private partnership with
community stakeholders family
stakeholders so early childhood programs
early learning programs
i'm hoping this part of this plan as
well as a strategic plan that was talked
about for early childhood birth through
age eight all the programs and services
that touch the life of a child and their
are there any other questions
see none thank you
up next is the deputy deputy
commissioner brennan
to speak for five minutes for technical
assistance
good afternoon almost i'm christine
brennan department of education deputy
commissioner as well as i chair the
council for thriving children
with our part with my partner trish
tilly from dhhs um just as just to back
up a little bit we did have a pdg
development grant for about 23 actually
the exact number is probably 28 million
dollars to help us with this work the
governor has asked us to um
develop uh office of early childhood and
that's what we are in the process right
now of doing with our green we hired a
facilitator
to help us with our strategic plan
greenway associates that's working with
the council
and you met some of the members here
that are on the council but it's also
other state agency commissioners as well
as some of our our partners
so i just wanted everyone to know if
they had any other specific questions if
i could answer them because it seemed to
be
i knew it was going to be you
representative ocala
thank you thank you for taking this
question
um it seems like a lot of
this
um
integration
promotion
and
promotion of parent knowledge
enhancement of interoperability
[Music]
expand access
and improve transitions all of this was
in in the scope of the council for
thriving children and so
um
how do you see
the
um
office of early childhood
role as
separate and distinct
from this or do you think that it would
susume all of these goals of the current
council i think that would um assume
many of the goals there and so i just
just to give it a little bit more
context
i think that um
when you think of the integration that's
needed
with um the department of health and
human services their their
joy restriction is really over the
family and
kids up to um four years old where the
department only has we have the children
from five on and this
works with kids b through eight and we
know that early interventions are the
best
indicators for kids to be successful in
school and so thinking about what are
some of the gaps or some of the
duplications and services that we can
improve in this office
and thinking of a mixed delivery service
for families because each child is so
unique
in what they need and each family is so
unique and what they need to be
successful in school and i'm thinking
about school and their education and
specifically when we think b through
eight
i'm thinking about that third grade
reading score
how do we make sure that these early
interventions can help our children be
are there any further representative all
chiller
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question um
so the executive order was issued on
january 23rd of 2020
which builds
it builds on the work that had already
begun in 2019
is there a sunset on that order the on
the executive order i'm not sure about
the executive order but i do know that
our grant ends this december okay of 22
and i there is whispers of an extension
on the grant of the money that's not
being funded but we can't make any plans
until something like that happens so
um
so to to that and i see some head
shaking that no there's not a sunset
happening behind you just so you know
thank you
so
um
the grant that is funding
the the
the work
to put together
a plan
is going to be up in december
and the uh plan
should be finished by november which
gives so if i'm if i'm tracking this
correctly as anyone who's worked with a
federal grant
you want to be done a little bit early
so that you can review
and also leave that room for a possible
extension application is that what i'm
hearing yes okay so this is all part of
reporting out the grant yes and
reporting to the letting the governor
know what our what what happens from the
um
from our strategic plan report to him
and um to hopefully fulfill his
um
ask in the executive order over an
office of early childhood thank you for
clarifying the timeline and the purpose
of this grant and why we're looking to
get this done by november it's not
you're saying it's not an
unreasonable ask because the work is
already happening exactly thank you
exactly it's been a nice blueprint laid
out so thank you very much for your
question
representative belanger
thank you madam chair and thank you for
being here and taking my question um so
slightly confused
there's obviously a cost to this
but
the fiscal note says that there's no
impact to costs i mean
so
excuse me one second just in here we're
about policy
okay finance worries about cost
i guess i'm just i'm confused where's
there's obviously a cost that can you
explain
where that cost is coming from
i ca so i think one like i'm going to go
with our madam chair that
right now it's what are our resources
that we have in the department of health
and human services what do we have in
department of education and what would i
think that the strategic plan and when
we work with these folks we can see
what's the best place for
the office of early childhood to sit and
what's probably the most fiscally
responsible
are there any further questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you and up next is anne-marie banfield
to speak in opposition to the pill and
she's bill and she's asked for three
minutes
thank you for the record my name is ann
ray banfield i'm a parental rights
advocate in new hampshire i tend to
speak at the house education and senate
education committees because my focus is
on academic excellence and education
i don't have any written testimony but i
did come here because actually you just
hit on my points um
i looked at this bill and i thought are
we expanding the bureaucracy as a
parental rights advocate i deal with
parents all the time
who have specific issues with their
children
and a lot of times it's not because we
don't have a bureaucracy it's because
they don't have access to what they need
um i'll give you just a for instance uh
there's been bills in in the in the
house education committee or senate
education committee focused on mental
health in the schools well i hear from
parents who have their kids
sitting in a hospital for a week waiting
on a bed to get into the one mental
health facility in the state and so i'm
looking at this going you want to spend
money in the schools on this but i've
got desperate parents whose children are
suicidal
and so when when you asked about the the
fiscal note that's exactly what i'm
looking at this going are we going to be
spending more money on this as a state
and we have to prioritize this i'm not
saying that this isn't important and if
we had unlimited resources maybe this is
something that we would look at but my
you know in and the the last speakers
brought up you know looking at reading
scores well oftentimes it's because
schools use faulty reading programs how
does how does the bureaucracy fix that
um so that's what i would just caution
you on is just you know are we expanding
a bureaucracy with limited resources and
if that's the case my plea to you
is to
speak to the parents speak to the people
who
who are trying to get access and yeah
maybe there are there are some hurdles
and you you heard that they're not going
to be removed maybe this would
streamline it somehow but if there is a
cost involved at all
i'm just not sure that that's where we
want to be spending our money i i think
we need to be make sure that we're
spending the money to reach the people
who need it so thank you for me thank
you for listening are there any
questions
seeing none thank you very much
simon close the public hearing on house
bill 326
and as soon as you're ready i'll start
the next one
you ready
all right
so
yeah if i wrote it on my thing thank you
yeah
okay so i'm going to open the public
hearing on sb 457
and i will call on senator sharon carson
thank you very much madam chair and good
morning to the members of the house
children and family law committee for
the record my name is sharon carson i
have the pleasure of representing senate
district 14 comprising the towns of
londonderry hudson and auburn and i have
this morning for your consideration
senate bill 457
which as it was introduced
establishes a committee to study
non-profit organizations
contracting with the department of
health and human services for children's
services madam chair this bill came
about because i was approached by
a number of entities
that are dealing with our department of
health and human services that are
non-profits
and they're finding it very very
difficult to get insurance
for many of them their insurance has
been canceled
and if they don't have insurance they
cannot continue to do business with the
state of new hampshire so what um what i
did was put together a study committee
to have us take a look at this
we're talking about giving some sort of
limited liability to these non-profits
and that
sometimes is not a very popular thing to
do
but i do think we have to
in one way or another address this issue
because the state does depend upon
nonprofits to carry out a lot of our
mission concerns especially concerning
children and we can't
i don't think it would be good policy to
let these organizations
go to the wayside just because we can't
seem to figure out a way to help them so
again this just creates a study
committee to look at this issue and come
forward and advise uh the legislature on
a path forward thank you very much madam
chair okay are there any questions
representative yokela
thank you thank you for taking the
question
um
the
so the hurdle that you're you're trying
to find out more about is um
that we may not be able to continue
doing business with certain
places because they don't have insurance
um do we know why they don't have
insurance and what is the
or why they are getting denied or maybe
that this is maybe
um
you know
an insurance
issue
and not um
like we already want to we want to be
in
working with them right but they are not
meeting our qualifications
through no fault of our own but maybe
through the the insurance industry is
that um what you have come to believe um
thank you for the question um
it has more to do with i think a lot of
it has to do with the insurance but
there are folks here from some of those
organizations who would be able to
answer your question uh much better than
representative belanger
uh thank you madam chair and thank you
senator for being here today just
my question comes in two part
if i may follow up after that madam
chair the first part is um
belanger non-profit
is denied insurance but it would be
easier for belanger llc to receive that
but we're still providing the same
quality of service correct this is i
again representative i don't deal with
the insurance aspect of it they're here
and they will be able to explain their
experience to you much better than i can
got it uh thank you uh senator and if i
may follow up
just to try to comprehend what's being
done here but
um
essentially this is seeking to
understand what's going on because we
don't quite understand what's going on
is is that
i think that thank you representative i
think that's part of it but it's also to
see if we can find a path forward to
deal with it because we have been doing
uh business as a state with some of
these organizations for a for a long
time and now they're faced with these
changes and again they're the
if you look at the duties it says the
committee shall study the feasibility
of extending limited liability nonprofit
organizations
so
um that's what you're going to do and
you will bring all the players to the
table and hopefully
this committee will be able to hammer
out whatever we need to hammer out so we
all set
are there any further questions
representative all chiller
thank you madam chair and thank you
senator for bringing this forward about
how many agencies are we talking about
um
thank you for the question i don't
believe we're talking so much about
agencies as we're talking about
nonprofits
um and there are some of them here who
would be able to talk about that much
better than i can
i hope i've answered your question
uh may i follow up yeah um
my bad for
using the wrong verbiage nonprofit and i
was thinking nonprofit agencies so my i
did not mean to confuse that with state
agencies um
so
about how many non-profits have
approached the state saying we're having
this quite frankly quite a few have
approached me on this particular issue
and in fact i was asked to bring in a
bill that would give them
that limited liability but we got a lot
of pushback from the attorneys
the trial attorneys and a number of
other organizations that just do not
like the idea of limited liability so
hopefully one of the charges of this
committee would be we're going to bring
these all people together all in a room
and hammer this out and figure out a way
forward
are there any further questions
seeing none thank you thank you very
much madam chair
up next is keith keaning from waypoint
and i have dominique whitten who is
thank you madam chair thank you members
of the committee good to see all of you
it's been a while um my name is keith
king for the record i'm the advocate
director at waypoint um
and we want to thank senator carson for
bringing forward this bill so in
2019 we brought forward a similar bill
asking for a limited liability um we had
not lost our insurance yet but we were
concerned that either we were going to
lose our insurance or that the premiums
were going to go up so high we wouldn't
be able to afford it the main program
that we're focused on here is the foster
care program it's called iso and um
dominique actually works in that program
and so i thought she could give you an
idea of what kind of kids and what kind
of needs these kids have about why it is
so important that this program is around
so this year um after that bill didn't
go forward and i believe the word that
was used was they didn't think the issue
was ripe enough at the time um that we
hadn't
the things that we were predicting
hadn't come true um now the things we
had predicted have come true we have
lost our umbrella insurance for our iso
program
once there's not a pattern make as my
mother would often say but now we've
also found out that spaulding youth
center has also lost their umbrella
insurance and so
i think what we're seeing out there is
with the large number of lawsuits that
are going forward especially when it
comes to foster care abuse and neglect
what's happened at the sununu center
there are a lot of people out there that
are reconsidering whether they should
look into suing the organizations that
and we are at a crisis point quite
honestly
we work in lieu of the state we do the
job that the state doesn't do
and if the state loses us i'm not sure
that there's going to be anybody around
to do the work that we can do that
doesn't mean over a number of years
maybe the state couldn't do that um but
right now they can't even fill all their
cpsw's positions let around to go out
and fire hire a whole new staff to
replace the people that need to order to
do this this kind of foster care and so
we truly are just looking for some kind
of committee um we think the answer
might be to limit our liability to what
dcys liability is it's 475 thousand
dollars
i can tell you there are organizations
that don't agree with that perhaps
there's a better solution out there
that we don't know about
but i think bringing lawmakers and the
different people together to say
these kids need protection how do we
find this protection and how do we
continue to support organizations that
want to give these services would be
really great so um i want to thank you
for your time i'm happy to take
questions now or if you want to wait
until after dominique speaks it's
whatever you want to do so thank you
representative yokola
thank you thank you for the
taking the question when you say you've
lost the insurance
do you mean that they refused to offer
you insurance or that you
declined the premiums
that they offered no thank you for the
question they informed us
that they would no longer provide an
umbrella policy for us we do have an
underlying policy of a million dollars
which as an attorney and as most of you
know in this day and age that's not a
lot of money especially when you're
looking at somebody bringing a lawsuit
from the point where they say they're 15
years old and this will have damaged
them for the rest of their lives we have
been told and spaulding has been told
that there is no umbrella policy for you
we do not have an option to buy it not
it wasn't presented to us at any cost we
could not get an umbrella policy
thank you representative belanger
uh thank you madam chair and thank you
mr cunning and i'm sorry i didn't catch
your name dominique dominique and thank
you for being here today um so
prefacing this i too understand
um with the the job that i have
i just found out that they were just
canceling us because they were no longer
doing it um so just just and i'll ask
you the same question that i asked the
senator
belanger
non-profit is providing ex-services to
the state
and
i get a phone call that
said services are no longer being
insured however belanger llc
is now
allowed to procure that insurance is is
that what's going on here
so thank you for the question i i have
no idea whether that that we i think
this is one of the reasons we would like
to have the committee to see where the
impact from these cancellations are
happening again that may be a solution i
i don't know all i can tell you is the
two non-profits that we know and
spalding is a pretty big organization
and they are very concerned about this i
i think the thing you have to understand
is
the children that we take
and the children that spalding takes
this is like juggling nitroglycerin
these kids have been through hell right
you are you're you're bringing and
taking care of kids that are incredibly
damaged and so when we take them on as a
client we're trying to solve problems
but it's very difficult for us not to
get pulled into things because these
kids have so many issues but whether we
could somehow part of us go back under
an llc or whether the private
corporations that provide this are
getting better insurance or whatever i'm
not sure representative but i think it
would be something that we need to have
answered and again i think the committee
would be able to pull people in we'd be
able to get the answers to this and then
as i've said before i don't think we're
we're just looking for one solution if
the cap is not the solution that's fine
with us we just want to be able to
provide the services to these children
that need it
and that's our goal
so thank you i don't know if that
i would have to say i'd have to look
into that deeper representative
representative smith
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question um what was the
reasoning behind
the insurance canceling you what did
they say did they say any any reason
so
thank you for the question
representative
they don't tell you why they're i'm
pulling the umbrella policy i will tell
you that this is
since all these things have started
happening
um
it's just
more and more people are coming forward
i think they just think it's just too
huge of a liability for them to take
this on and they'd rather just walk away
from it than to possibly get on the hook
for um a verdict that could leave them
millions and millions and millions of
dollars that they have to pay out um as
i said you know when these kids are i
think some of you remember back there
was a case where
you know two kids were taking into the
bathroom by their parents this was i
don't believe this was an iso one but
those children were sexual excuse me it
was a parent parent but those children
were sexually abused by the parents
during that
incident
and i believe the payout was someplace
in the seven million dollar range so i
think a lot of these i think a lot of
these insurance companies are just
saying
you know what these kids are really
damaged to begin with and we're just not
going to take the risk of going you know
it's kind of like
right you can't buy flood insurance near
the ocean that has to be a federal
program because most of the insurance
companies say it's just too dangerous
and i think that's where we are we
didn't get an explanation but i can i
can guarantee you that's what's going on
representative ocala thank you
thank you for
taking the question
um
it seems like
you are wanting
the study of
um
specific
organizations that
the non-profit organizations that deal
with
the contract with department of human
services
and not
all non-profit organizations having the
option to be
um
be a limited liability and then i
i don't really understand how you would
um
know
before you've made your declaration of
like this is my business and this is my
type of business how would you qualify
for
like if you're not allowing all
non-profits to be limited liability then
you would apply after you form the
business you start doing good work then
you contract with uh
with dhhs and say okay now you want you
want to hire us to do this work now
we're going to get limited liability
like
um
in a different class classification than
do you see that that is
like like a restructuring of the
business like midstream
as
something that is problematic and you
would really think that you should be
allowing all uh
um
non-profits to have limited liability or
are you really just seeking a special
like reformation of the business once
they get a contract with dhhs
sir so if it's all right dominique would
like to so
a lot of the problem that's coming up
with the insurance is because iso and
child placing agencies are working
directly with the state
and because of dcyf's history and
juvenile justice's history and the level
of risk that these children are exposed
to when they're not placed with their
parents
that's putting a lot of burden on our
programs to go and do
a lot of extra work and verification
as far as uh an iso agency being
for-profit or not-for-profit my personal
opinion and this is not the opinion of
i'm not representing waypoint when i say
this the service needs to take place
these children need the help
and so if we're putting the service
providers at a higher level of risk for
taking this work from the state because
the state has a cap and we don't
we're not only putting ourselves in
danger when we're walking into
homes
that have significant child welfare
concerns significant safety concerns but
we're also putting
our agencies at a higher level of risk
because we can't control all of the
outcomes we don't have decision making
power and i can reflect a little bit
more on that in my testimony but really
what's happening is we're being made
responsible for decisions that aren't
ours to make
well it would be all right if i answered
the question also madam chair yeah
so representative i mean if we said that
we wanted to expand it to all nonprofits
i think every non-profit in the state
would cheer i also think you'd have so
many trial attorneys in here we wouldn't
be able to breathe so i think what we've
learned over the years is that we try
and we've talked to i've talked to
marissa we've talked to people from the
trial attorneys
i think good legislation comes from
solving the problem in front of you we
don't want to be too broad
and and what we're bringing to you
is what's happening to one particular
program at this particular moment and i
i i think what i've learned over my past
10 years of advocacy is not to try to go
beyond that too far because then you're
solving problems that don't exist and so
and i think you have to understand there
are different programs with different
levels of liability and risk and this
program the reason the insurance
companies have stopped this insurance is
because the risk on this program is so
incredibly high because the children
have been through so such terrible
circumstances and so
i i guess what i'm saying to you is i'm
sure the non-profit community would love
to have their liability limited to 475
but we have tried to explain it to
everybody we've talked to including the
trial attorneys we're asking for
something very specific here on this
particular program where the state hires
us in lieu of their efforts we need
protection because we no longer have an
umbrella policy and that's all we're
okay
are there any further questions
representative long
thank you madam chair uh
with
is there any possibilities that
in
high risk situations such as this
you could pay the premium to the state
to cover
you
you know thank you representative it's a
great question i mean i think some of us
i reflect back on i believe this
happened to the
ob gyns years ago right where they had
this established some kind of state fund
because they were having difficulty
finding reasonable insurance as i said
at the beginning of the testimony we
came up with the solution
saying to limit our liability there may
be a better solution through this
through this through the insurance
department and we'd love to sit down
with the trial attorneys and others and
try to find the solution all we're
asking we're trying to find a solution
that keeps our program open
to keep helping the children
that's our bottom line that's all we
want to achieve and if there's different
ways to achieve that we are more than
welcome to hear what those are and there
may be other solutions and if the state
would like to get involved in that way
um that would be fine too
very good thank you
are there any further questions
seeing none thank you very much
can i ask you a question
so um dominique was just going to tell
you just about some of the children that
are in this program would you like her
to expand on that or since the questions
have gone on so long that's up to you
madam chair she was just going to tell
you would you mind just just telling
them no go ahead is that all right oh
yeah okay all right so iso services are
wrap around services for families that
are involved in child welfare to the
extent that they are either at imminent
risk of placement
or they've already received a finding we
work with
individuals involved in juvenile justice
and we work with families that are
involved with child welfare
the services that we provide um
their intention is to prevent
institutionalization
their intention is to make sure that the
family has an opportunity to reunify
and if the family can't reunify the
child has the the ability to build
trusting relationships with adults so
that they don't wind up in a long-term
institutionalization situation
we do some pretty life-saving work both
and with their parents
for parents a lot of our work is to
address safety barriers to them like
substance abuse domestic violence
significant criminal activity
and then for the children we're working
with children who have been put
significantly at risk i've worked with
children who have fallen from windows
several stories up i've worked with
children who have
experienced firearms
being let off in the home
and i've also worked with children
who've gone through some really
traumatic loss
related to domestic violence and all of
these children are serious by these
programs regardless of who they are all
there is a really good reason that this
service isn't provided by the state of
new hampshire and that is that the state
of new hampshire as we've all heard
commissioner ribson say is a law
enforcement agency child protective
services and juvenile justice and
probation their job is to make decisions
that are going to impact the lives of
these children our job is to provide
treatment
and our job is to provide them with the
information that they need to make a
choice
um
asking the state to take on that work
really disrupts the trust it reduces
clinically evident practices and
services and it would likely reduce the
amount of time that these children and
these families are getting from their
service providers
and just lastly and i promise i won't
say another thing unless i'm asked
i think the difference between foster
care and what dominique does is foster
care they might check in on them once a
month
literally iso programs they're they're
checked in five times a week that's how
much care these kids need that they have
an entire staff of people coming in to
talk to these kids and help these kids
and so that's why i keep saying these
kids are at the deep end of need and
that's why it's so hard to
how how desperately we need to protect
them so i will stop there but thank you
for your time everyone are there any
all right seeing them thanks so much
thank you
and up next is marissa chase from the
new hampshire association for justice
good morning madam chair morning still
yes
members of the committee thank you for
allowing me to speak today
i represent the new hampshire
association for justice which is a
statewide organization of professional
trial attorneys so we are the trial
attorneys that have been mentioned i
wasn't planning to testify today
you know we we support the concept of a
committee to study these issues rather
than the blanket
you know liability protection that was
suggested in 2020 we vehemently oppose
that bill
as drafted because it's so expansive you
know when you're talking about taking
away liability that's really taking away
accountability and as we heard these
kids are in high risk scenarios
there are a couple of points i just
wanted to make one
we have met with keith would love to
continue speaking with keith and folks
at waypoint
i believe and keith can correct me if
i'm wrong there are about 10
organizations in the state that
currently provide iso iso services
it is no doubt been proven by data since
the 1930s that kids who are in bad homes
do better staying in those homes and
getting services like iso than they do
going and being institutionalized
the problem we have is that
if you take if you
you cannot write any one specific entity
into statute so
while waypoint i believe from our
research has only been named in a
lawsuit once in the past 10 years the
other organizations have been named
much more often
and there are some really troubling
facts out there so we're trying to
find a way that iso services can still
be provided without granting immunity to
these other organizations who may
provide iso services but are also
engaging in negligent hiring and their
staff are abusing children
so i understand it's a tricky balance to
make it's you know i s no doubt that iso
is a very um important
function for about i think it's between
130 130 to 150 families a year but 130
to 150 families a year versus thousands
of kids
in other placement entities
run by some of these same organizations
so
i'd be happy to provide follow up with
written testimony
with some of our concerns but again
we like the idea of a study committee to
really get down to the heart of these
issues and be able to have those
conversations
okay are there any questions
representative long
thank you madam chair thank you for your
testimony um it is it possible you may
not be able to answer it but i think
your trial attorneys may uh
is it a possibility for the state to
contract the insurance for these high
risk
entities
i don't know
i did a survey
through our national organization to
find out if this has been approached in
other states you know this idea of
limiting liability for these private
placement entities i could not find any
any surrounding states that have been um
looking into that as a possibility so i
i don't know if that if there's like a
blueprint out there for that i just
representative ocala
thank you thank you for taking the
question
when you're talking about um
these
um
maybe not waypoint but
other companies um
being held liable for their employees
doing things that were inappropriate
um
it see
it seems like
the question um that waypoint is trying
to address is
um
things that
may have happened that are outside their
control and not actually
um not necessarily that they're trying
to shirk responsibility for what they've
done but for things that they haven't
done
that that maybe decisions were made by
the state or a different person they
were just there
right and and they
were not law enforcement so they can't
can't do you know arrest someone or
something like that that's creating some
some hazard but may
may
if they don't handle it correctly be
held liable for
for that um
do you think that it would be possible
to
limit the liability of things that they
don't have direct control over without
creating
uh the light the protection for things
that they are doing that are imp
incorrect
so i will start i'm trying to get my
thoughts here um
there's a legal principle called
responded superior
that means when
you are
a business
you assume responsibility for your
employees
and that's a way for the business to
ensure that they are you know meeting
all the you know licensing requirements
requirements or accountability that are
out there you know they're in compliance
um
so the way to change a bad actor
is to hold them accountable
um
so even though
you know
keith at waypoint may not be directly
responsible for
something that goes on in a home
you know the organization is responsible
for their activities
i will also say it is very difficult to
bring any of these lawsuits there's a
court rule superior court rule 40 that
caps attorney's fees at 25 when they're
representing children um that is not
great incentive for any lawyer to bring
these cases because these cases are
taken on contingency fee that means that
the lawyer fronts all the costs of
litigation up front and only gets paid
if and when they are successful and
again their fees will be capped so the
attorneys that take these cases are
really um
it's out of a public interest
um i could think of one attorney who's a
former public defender who has taken a
few of these cases against these private
placement facilities only when there is
criminal conduct found and it's been
referred to him by a public interest
lawyer that says hey like
this is really bad what's going on here
can you take a look
i don't know if that directly answered
your question our concern with the
legislation introduced in 2020 was that
the way it was drafted it would apply to
anyone who contracts with the state so
someone joked oh if pinara caters an
executive council meeting can they will
they
be granted limited liability so i
understand that there is a very careful
balancing act that needs to take place
and i'm looking forward to a greater
discussion
i don't know if i answered your question
i apologize
saying no representative smith
thank you madam chair thank you for your
you your the iso works directly with
dcyf correct
i i don't work for
um the iso
okay
yes okay yeah so i was just wondering
why you wouldn't fall under that dcyf
sure
no come on up more the more the merrier
from your mouth to god's ear
well there's your answer
you know i think i i i do think
that the trial attorneys have
a point
i think this goes back to what
representative was saying too we're
being pulled into things
because of what other things are
happening around us and that's affecting
our ability to serve these kids and i i
think marissa
we have that very you know civilized
conversations and i look forward to
having those also but i think the
question becomes how do you solve this
problem perhaps just in this iso and let
me make very clear
we are not asking this just for waypoint
we're asking for iso you know iso
programs so right
excuse me i'm sorry could you speak into
the mic sir so that it's
so people listening at home
on you marissa can i have a follow-up
um
so
how does the child get services from you
once dcyf is
involved correct they refer they refer
the family okay so i just i was just
wondering if you could be under their
umbrella where your contract you're kind
of contracted by them
so that thank you for the question that
is what we're requesting that if we're
if we're working in lieu of the state
and contracting with the state on a
particular iso programs
and if if the other bill was
too broad we're asking for a narrower
definition now is that per because of
the high risk of these children that we
would have our liability limited to the
state on those pro on that particular
program and not just for waypoint but
for any agency that deals with these
kids
okay thank you answer your question yes
yes thank you
all right seeing none thank you very
much
thank you and madam chair if i may just
one last comment um
when we're talking about people getting
pulled into other lawsuits there is a
practice where you know it's not just
the plaintiff attorneys just going out
naming everyone there's a case that has
become great precedent called the
benedetto and keith and i have talked
about that before and that's where to
shift the burden of liability defendants
will name co-defendants because they try
to spread out responsibility so that
they are not accountable solely so
plaintiff attorneys aren't always the
bad guys i guess is what i'm trying to
say
okay we'll take note of that thank you
all right thank you
okay so i'm gonna close the public
hearing i'm
so next week we have scheduled
three bills
that and then i am hopeful that after
those we'll be able to exec
um all of our bills so we don't have to
come back another day if it's if it's
not necessary i mean if we
if we run into something that you know
we need to then we'll have to but if we
can so any proposed amendments for the
bills we heard today or whatever if you
want to
anybody wants to get them or whatnot and
then to
the republicans we will caucus at nine
o'clock next tuesday
is everybody else that was the only
senate bills we have these and the ones
that for next week
yep there's three for next week yeah
yeah they're they they were left in in
yeah that's the sununu one that she said
she was gonna get so
all right and then we will go to lunch
and we'll be back at 1.
madam chair yeah
uh
the chair of edna came in this morning
just
wanted to ensure that some people will
be going to
their the joint hearing yeah i'm going
okay great and and anybody else that
wants to go well
you're gonna have to stay here and run
if we're if we're not done
by that time but
yeah i'm hoping that the last bill won't
take
that long so we can all go to edna
yeah i'm i'm planning to go to judiciary
because we're having some of our bills
heard in judiciary to testify that and
so that's why we're kind of spread all
over the place
yeah welcome to the legislature okay
right i just wanted to because she came
in and wanted to make sure that
hopefully that someone will come but if
someone will oh yeah i plan on being
okay great
all right so um
everyone enjoy your lunch i'll see you
together
okay good afternoon everyone
um i'm gonna go ahead and
open the public hearing on sb 336
and i will call in senator suprentist
who's asked for five minutes oh there
good afternoon um again for the record
my name is sue prentice i'm the state
senator from district five which is nine
there's nine communities in the
beautiful
connecticut river valley of new
hampshire good afternoon
chair rice and members of house children
and family law committee for the record
again i've already stated my name and
i'm here today to introduce senate bill
which establishes qualifications and the
appropriate instances of inclusion of
qualified family mediator interns and i
just want to say on the outside i have
very brief testimony and i have
members of the family mediator um
certified family mediator community here
with me this uh has to do with some
cleanup that was requested by the
judicial branch and it's also
a workforce bill because by doing this
cleanup more family mediators can be
trained and go through internships so i
just wanted to put that on the record
and i will
follow with my introduction so the
family major family mediator
certification board is a small
occupational regulatory board under the
office of professional licensure and
certification
that regulates divorce and parenting
mediators
certified family mediators assist
parents facing divorce and separation
resolve family issues without the court
in order to become a certified family
mediator a student must complete an
internship however the pathway to these
internships needs to be cleared as the
absence of official language recognizing
these qualified interns and that's
defined under rsa 328 c 5 1
and 2 a and c as part of the proceedings
has become a barrier so what they're
saying is in these sections without this
proper definition we can't have these
qualified
interns in
anywhere within the judicial system
training
and again
esther
hester
they can provide further clarification
this legislation would go far for
solving the problem by opening up these
internship opportunities and officially
recognizing interns in the proceedings
as required by the judicial branch i
asked the committee for your support on
and on to pass motion or on past
recommendation i should say
and this was amended in the senate and
the the amendment that was made by
senate judiciary had to do with making
sure that interns these qualified
interns they couldn't be alone
in a proceeding or alone in a room they
had to have you know restrict
supervision and that was a again an
amendment that was made by senate um
judiciary and so that with that i will
thank you i will close my testimony i
will for my introduction and testimony
and happy to take any questions you
might have okay
okay we'll see none thank you very much
thank you i will stay stick around and
if you have any i'll be here thanks
thank you
and up next is um marianne dempsey
from the juju judicial branch for
good afternoon members of the committee
um i
indicated i would be less than a minute
so get your watches ready um we
appreciate the opportunity to work with
the sponsor but the folks from the
mediation um
group who to who drafted this
legislation it addresses the concern the
judicial branch had regarding
confidentiality we are certainly
supportive of the role mediation has
particularly in family law cases so
we are here to to state that it does
address our concerns and i'm happy to
take any questions okay are there any
questions
representative altschiller
thank you madam chair thank you very
much
the program um
the program exists now yes and um this
is there an expectation that with
further clarification our program will
be more attractive
you know i the program is it our
mediation program um certainly has a
large number of participants um there
was 1800 i believe family law mediations
in the past year
this is really to allow
folks to obtain the training by
participating in those mediations so
that um they're then able to conduct
them themselves so i see the jewish
branch only sees it as a positive thing
i don't know that it'll be more
mediations but it may be more trained
mediators and that's always a good thing
follow-up
thank you and um
if we grow our capacity for
family mediators by expanding on this
internship program um
will that pave the way for further
opportunities here to keep those interns
as state residents doing mediation maybe
i i would see that as certainly a
benefit to this to this program as well
i'm
sure that the sponsor and the committee
could could speak to that but from the
court perspective we welcome
um the intern and the and the
educational opportunities
okay are there any further questions
all right seeing none thank you very
much thank you for your time
up next is honey hastings
is a family mediator correct
she's asked for five minutes and does
have written testimony and she is also
passing out testimony from someone who
there you go is that it yeah good thank
you
um
that's new
i haven't been here in person since that
happened it's a good it's a plus i've
been watching you
and other committees of interest
my name's honey hastings i'm a retired
lawyer and i've been a mediator uh
certified mediator since 2000.
i
the problem is that people are having
trouble getting internship hours and
thus they don't become certified
they do not then
be able to offer their services to the
court who
screens people and chooses the people
they want but there's a smaller pool
because of this
problem
and
when the court indicated the reason that
they changed the policy and said that
interns could not work in the co-mediate
in the system was some changes were
needed in the statute
well you know me
changes in the statute
you know that's that's a solvable
problem
and with
your support added to that we got in the
senate judiciary this problem will be
solved
um
the
at this point they're only interns only
allowed to observe
and um
so there's the shortage of people and um
in fact there are two emails that i
think you got one from linda bauer was a
licensed social worker and she got the
training
but she couldn't get the internship
hours so she is not a certified mediator
and it would have been her particular
background skills would have been a nice
addition to the profession
maybe when the bill passes she'll be
able to do that there's also susannah
schweitzer sent in an email it took her
more than a year to get the internship
hours she did succeed in doing it and is
now certified
so there's the numbers thing there's
qualified people being able to get the
internships and thus
be able to do the court work but there's
also court cases are different in my
experience i did court work for a lot of
years
they're often tougher cases
private mediation people haven't filed
court papers haven't started making
charges back and forth haven't had court
events
um
and they're often
not as antagonistic towards each other
people have been in court have had a
losing decision and a temporary hearing
and then sent to mediation
um
they're tougher they're tougher and also
there's more cases where the parties
were never married to each other
i don't if only had very few private
cases with that scenario most of them
are divorces and somehow those never
married cases are tougher
maybe they only had a brief dating
relationship you know they have no good
times to look back on
so
not having the experience with the court
the mix of court cases is a disadvantage
um i think in addition to just the
number of of people become coming in
this this bill is a product of a
committee called the future of certified
family medias that was set up by the
chair of the new hampshire conflict
resolution association because
we were all talking about it within the
profession and it it seemed like it was
something that it would be hard for the
board itself to take on there
especially because as i'll speak later
they're having trouble with quorums
so we went off a bunch of us that were
interested in policy and came up with it
um
it essentially breaks down the
internship into two steps
all the steps for becoming certified
other than the internship are step one
if you get all those papers and courses
and training in and the board reviews it
you can become a qualified intern a new
term
you then have to get the internship
hours and only when you add the
internship hours to the paperwork
and training
can you
possibly become a certified mediator by
breaking it down the court is assured
that the people that are being brought
in as interns have
the suitable training and education and
background check etc all the things that
have to happen other than the internship
in fact i think it may even lead to if
this bill passes to more mediators being
willing to take on interns because they
will also be reassured
that the qualified interns have already
so i think that this
will have a very positive effect on the
availability of
mediators
the next to last paragraph in the bill
was something that was also added in the
senate and it's because the board has
had a continuing quorum problem in fact
the board was to meet today
and it's not because it's lacking a
quorum
in 2021
the occupational many occupational
regulatory boards had their statutes
amended to replace a number for a quorum
to the language that says a majority of
the members of the board appointed by
governor and council shall constitute a
quorum
somehow they didn't get this magic
language in for the mediator board
the mediator board needs it because it's
got two
members that are appointed by the
judicial branch
and in fact one of them can't attend
today and it's the reason why there's no
quorum
so if you would simply add that
you know that's a kind of it's a small
minor issue and yet the board repeatedly
has not been able to have its meetings
due to lack and this is why we asked the
senate to add this and they did
um
i i'd be happy to review
of course i answer any questions i'd be
happy to review the sections of the bill
if people want
that
whatever would be helpful
questions all right seeing none thank
you
up next is esther wolf and i just want
to apologize i have to be somewhere at 1
30 so i may have to run out
if we're not done
um
um esther wolfe to speak in support of
the bill and she is a certified mediator
supervisor and trainer
hello everyone good afternoon thank you
for your time um and all you give to the
state of new hampshire
i actually see no downside to this
proposed legislation
i i've been mediating
actually since we were certifying family
meteors in in new hampshire and so which
is back in the early 90s and
i think the re specific to the
to the the legislation
and i think really an important piece is
being able to create the level of and
volume of opportunities for people to
intern with with um certified family
mediators a lot of whom um are court
contracted i do i do i have a private
practice with the business partner but
honestly the bulk of work that we do for
a lot less money than if we're in
private cases is with the court and
those can be some of the most
challenging cases which frankly
interests me and
our goal in general as professional
mediators is to try to provide the
highest level of of services to our
community here in new hampshire and
where else you know we may serve people
and and to do that is to be able to
provide the opportunities for more
internships and more um hands-on active
if appropriate co-mediation comedian
observation is you sit and watch and you
and i i have used this before and you
know anyone who's in the room with me i
don't care who they are signs of
participation agreement and
it takes the pledge of confidentiality
frankly i think it's always been that
way but i think we need to reassure
people about that um
um
you know when when so i i do think that
once people take the program of
instruction which is part of that first
component um and they have to work
really hard to find in i you know
internships i i my i do have interns i
have a couple now so and other people do
as well including my business partner
but but um a lot of people have found
that they've gotten turned down and
and i think that where no one gets paid
more than a modest amount for any court
case it might be easier for some of the
certified meteors to feel like they can
take on an intern
as part of that process
but i came from mediation this morning
over in brentwood and you know it was um
and it reminds me why do what i do and
and because people are coming in at the
one of the hardest times and they need
help getting apart so whether you're
the
therapist who honey mentioned uh linda
brewer who and and i know her i trained
her and frankly she's doing some
internship time with me at the moment
but only under observation and i'm
waiting for my next private case
but um i think that those are just
in general more challenging you know i i
whether you're dealing with millionaires
or people who who come in and know
they're supposed to pay and can't
and you have to learn to deal with all
those things with professionally and and
grace and
um i think that there are more
opportunities to do that through the
i can only see this as a bonus right
this is going to get more mediators we
already know we're short on them which
is causing more problems in the back up
of the courts
correct
absolutely absolutely it's better i just
had to perform it into questions
oh yeah oh okay okay hold on so
you know
honestly i've been mediating um in and
out of the courts since the mid-80s and
i meeting probably in most counties and
most courts and i on occasion used to
get called from a court saying hey hey
who's this person who's like does this
mediation and and because they had some
people who especially some of the
parenting cases and the post-divorce
cases where they're truly high conflict
no communication cases and there's a
huge need and it's why i've chosen to
focus on family and you know some
appropriate as well family from kind of
pre-birth to to death cases because it's
so important and it helps de-escalate
situations to help parents do what they
need to do
which so anyways but yes there is a real
need for it and and there is a shortage
and i do hope that more people will take
on interns you know with the passing of
this legislation so
all right great thank you so much thank
you so much okay so that was my last
pink card so i'm going to close the
house the
um
yes
so i tell those kind of cases